der unternehmer christoph dicken von
oettinger hat er ein leben lang bei
seinen investments ein glückliches
händchen
außer bei der fabrik in kigali
er war der größte arbeitgeber in ruanda
bis der völkermord 1994 alles zerstört
was damals geschah hat ihn lange
verfolgt erst jetzt 20 jahre später ist
dicken bereit wieder nachgegangen zu
fliegen
vor wieder nicht start sino sind
maschine logo sind gegebenenfalls
maschine weg natürlich interessiert mich
sehr
markus mannebach treffen und wird
aufseher celle hat oder wie jetzt
erzählt wie er das überlebt hat und was
er erlebt hat mit der guten toren
von der firma gut an da sind heute 20
jahre später nur noch akten kisten übrig
francesco cilea damals die technischen
anlagen der fabrik installiert und
bringt seine alten unterlagen vorbei
christoph dicken möchte sich mit ihm
zusammen auf seine reise nach kigali
vorbereiten
die erste überlegung sie zum ganze
dickens wärme gut stellte aus
einheimischen papyrus robuste
dachplatten her
sie waren leichter billiger und
isolierten besser als das herkömmliche
wellblech die idee eines nachhaltigen
produktes begeisterte christoph dicken
das produkt hergestellt wird die land wo
ihnen die möglichkeit gz spruch die
devise von name und hauptsächlich das
produkt zur setzte wogt der wiese
verschlingt das ich metall dass sich
chaves testament dass ich egal was das
produkt und die papyrus phase ist
natürlich hundertmal besser
der heute 75 jährige unternehmer besaß
schon damals ein weltweit tätiges
unternehmen das aus altpapier
dachplatten fertigte am projekt in
ruanda reizte ihn die gute idee und die
herausforderung in einem
entwicklungsland eine fabrik zu bauen
und besonders dass sie wirklich der tvt
stunde rund laufe ja und wenn sie
zwischen tour-abstecher riesensauerei
quillt über altpapierpreise muss alles
auf mich alles entleeren
robin hat sich der ursprüngliche bekomme
ich für sehr zuverlässige infrastruktur
und das sind natürlich schon die erste
zeichen dass es nicht richtig
am 6 april 1994 brach in ronda ein
unvorstellbar grausamer bürgerkrieg aus
organisierte banden gingen auf die
minderheit der tutsi es los und
ermordeten in nur 100 tagen fast eine
million menschen
auch viele mitarbeiter von gut eine
drohende waren tot auf google earth hat
dicken zu seiner verblüffung entdeckt
dass auf dem areal eine andere fabrik
steht
von einem verkauf oder einer enteignung
weise aber nicht die spieler nach
genozid wally klage wurde vom minister
und mich dann der fußgänger weil mir der
größte arbeitgeber im land sie sind vor
dem genozid es mit das lied das bauen
seit jahren später b aber ich sehe wie
viel geld mehr
es müsste also die alte bankschulden
opfer wurde hätte jemand mit dem
oratorium mal zugestellt werden immer
alles besprochen jedes detail ist alles
still geworden die kälte erst das geld
bei mir jetzt erstmal wieder verdient
und so weiter und so fort dann
schlussendlich schnitt passiert und sind
wunder wie süd bewusst ihren
eigentlich wollte christoph dick nie
mehr nach ruanda zurückkehren
doch die entdeckung auf google earth hat
die neugierig gemacht
jetzt ist
wolfgang
kasa begleitet christoph dicken als
fahrer und guide die nächsten fünf tage
und 21
damit ist die chance die ich sehe
der erste morgen christoph dicken wartet
in der hotellobby auch seinen damaligen
lokalen geschäftspartner der einen
kleinen anteil an der firma hatte
berta mag user ein tutsi die den genozid
wie durch ein wunder überlebt hat
berta makus überlebte weil die damalige
schweizer botschaft sekretärin
marie-france 31 andere zu hause abholte
und mit hilfe eines ehemaligen hutu
offiziers in das uhr bewachte hotel mit
cholin brachte zu sehen das ist ihr
gutgeht hand hast du überlebt hat ich
hatte ein riesen glück
ich habe viele freunde verloren brüder
meine eltern es war schrecklich
ich kann euch versichern dass man da
jetzt das stabilste land in
zentralafrika ist jetzt wirklich ruhe
und ordnung und dann als held mac user
das gute mit ruanda 2002 von der
geschäftsbank versteigert worden sei das
gekauft und das gebäude wurde von der
ruandischen firma in lange industries
gekauft
wer steckt hinter dieser firma eine
private firma
über zwei stunden lang haben sich die
beiden ehemaligen geschäftspartner
vieles zu erzählen welche rolle berta
makusha beim ende der gut mit ruanda
genau spielte ist christoph dicken nicht
ganz klar geworden
im hotelzimmer geht er in gedanken das
wiedersehen nochmals durch honig gang
mit dem wertheimer kubanisches überhaupt
so schönes wiedersehen
sie erhält sie freudig habe mich gefreut
und dann haben wir dann langsam versucht
mal das gewesene auf arbeiter oder er
hat versucht mir das gewesen jetzt
erzähle in der zwischenzeit treter auf
englisch was mich sehr erstaunt hat das
hat nämlich nicht können wohl nicht das
letzte mal zeit und zwar kein wort
können
und jetzt kann man ganz gut englisch es
mir also erzählt dass die maschine und
das gebäude als ganzes ihre doppelten
versteigert wurde
wo er seitdem wusste nicht wem das
glaube ich ihm aber nett das kann nicht
möglich sie und dass der steigerung es
wahrscheinlich dazu dienten die alte
schulden ab strecke
das rätsel was mit seiner fabrik
geschehen ist macht ihn umso neugieriger
sie endlich mit eigenen augen wieder zu
sehen
die fahrt führt ihn durch ein sichtbar
verändertes kigali
die regierung möchte eine infrastruktur
nach westlichem vorbild straßen werden
geteert und unterhalten plastiksäcke
sind aus umweltgründen verboten
überall wird gebaut
[Musik]
die sicherheit steht zuoberst
die englischen bezeichnungen rudow und
tut sie wurden abgeschafft
es gibt nur noch woanders
[Musik]
neue schulen werden gebaut im
rohstoffarmen land soll eine
wissensorientierte gesellschaft
entstehen
halb so groß wie die schweiz muss ruanda
elf millionen menschen ernähren
baird am akku saat vorgespurt damit sie
die neue fabrik anschauen können
auch er ist das erste mal da aber es
beschäftigt luft 234 voll
sicherheitslücke
[Musik]
es wird genau wie husten blau oberhemd
uhr knurrt aber vor dort wo die
grünfläche jahr fand bis zum ende
grünfläche show so bauxit sind sagt
möckel at and power conditioner partitur
und hans turck mir hängt ja einfach auch
für akw giftig 2010 hat staatspräsident
paul kagame die neue fabrik höchst
persönlich eingeweiht
wo früher papyrus für die dachplatten
gewechselt wurde wird jetzt milch
abgefüllt
der direktor von in lange industries
weiß nicht richtig wasser den beiden
besuchern zeigen soll
er hat die fabrik bauen auf dem rundgang
ist christoph dicken sehr beeindruckt
von der modernen und teuren anlage er
erfährt vom direktor dass der
vorzeigebetrieb einem firmenkonglomerat
namens crystal ventures angehört und
versucht mehr über diese firma
herauszufinden der firma an der börse
kotiert privaten aktionären ist aber
keine öffentliche gesellschaft hier
wurde die papiere sind kleine stücke
geschnitten
ok
ich kann mit vielen es ist 20 jahre her
wir haben frieden deshalb tut alles noch
mal zu sehen
damit wir verdauen und vergessen können
größere bekannt ist
ok
offenbar wollen weder magna noch der
direktor damit herausrücken wer hinter
christel ventures steckt immerhin ist
man sich einig dass in christoph dick
ins alter fabrik etwas gutes für die
ruandische bevölkerung entstanden ist
schön dass wenigstens unsere
anstrengungen dem ruandischen volk
zugute kommen nicht ins portemonnaie
aber dem land
hätte es wehgetan vor 20 jahren schon
aber jetzt ist es vorbei
man muss fordert schaue nicht zurück sie
haben sich weiterentwickelt wie es ist
nur geld und energie die man hier
verbraucht hat so ganz ungerührt wer tut
ist er doch nicht er möchte wenigstens
wissen wie seine firma in den besitz von
christel ventures geraten ist und wer
dahinter steckt die bank kommerziell der
wanda war vor dem genozid teilweise an
der finanzierung beteiligt und soll vor
zehn jahren die zwangsversteigerung
durchgeführt haben
das treffen mit dem bankdirektor wird
aber kurzfristig abgesagt
ob die firmen konkurs gemacht hat oder
ob das versteigerte er will soziallasten
in der bank ist nichts zu machen
beim handelsregisteramt erhofft sich
dicken mehr informationen über güter mit
ruanda wann wurde der eintrag im
handelsregister gelöscht gibt es eine
abrechnung über die liquidation
wer hat die fabrik gekauft
die ernüchterung ist groß die firma ist
verschwunden
die gründungsurkunde muss hier seien die
firma war hier eingetragen nicht in der
schweiz
obwohl christoph dicken überrascht war
wie hilfsbereit und professionell das
handelsregisteramt war finden konnten
sie nichts
dieses amt gibt es erst seit 2003 und es
ist teil des regierungsplans aus kigali
eine handelsdrehscheibe zu machen
hier soll ein afrikanisches singapur
entstehen das größte bauprojekt im
zentrum von kigali gehört
überraschenderweise christoph dickens
alten geschäftspartner ragusa
ragusa baut nicht nur dieses riesige
shopping center er ist auch der grösste
matratzenhersteller des landes geworden
christoph dicken ist erstaunt zu sehen
zu welchem wohlstand es sein ehemaliger
geschäftspartner nach dem krieg gebracht
hat
peter frese
60.000 quadratmeter vermietbare fläche
soll hier entstehen
wer alle geschäfte im zukünftigen
shoppingcenter mieten soll ist aber laut
marco sei noch nicht klar
ich glaube auch dass viele sachen die er
weiß er mir ne zeit als ich glaube er
tischte er versucht mir vor als ob
notelf die wüste von dem was er effektiv
weiß ich dass in der liquidation vor
sie gehen sie im bau ich kann mir
vorstellen dass er privatperson 50 60
quadratmeter baut mit die in kigali
nicht weiß was mir für mich ist das ein
buch mit sehr viele fragezeichen
für christoph dicken liegt der verdacht
nahe dass barracuda von der
versteigerung seiner firma profitiert
hat aber den finanziellen verlust hat er
längst verdaut und vorwürfe macht er
seinem ehemaligen geschäftspartner keine
irgendwie musste markus ja nach dem
genozid eine neue existenz aufbauen
unterdessen hat sich herum gehört und
herausgefunden wer hinter christel
vengeance steckt anscheinend gemäß
unserem live show führte christian lüth
wurde zum präsident stand der völkermord
an den tutsis wurde damals nach 100
tagen von rebellion der ruandischen
patriotischen front beendet
ihr anführer war paul kagame seit 2000
ist er gewählter staatspräsident das
volk liebt ihn weil er eine maßgebliche
rolle an der stabilisierung und den
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung hat
international wird ihm aber vorgeworfen
dass er für das enorme tempo mit dem er
an darauf baut demokratische grundrechte
missachtet diese präsident ist also
christoph dickens letzte hoffnung mehr
über den verbleib seiner fabrik zu
erfahren
der präsident empfängt medien sonst sehr
selten aber christoph dicken und das
reporterteam unternehmen einen versuch
ihn zu treffen
christoph likens name als ehemals größte
arbeitgeber von ronda klingt
offensichtlich noch nach und es klappt
mit der audienz bei staatspräsident paul
kagame christoph dicken erzählt die
geschichte von guter nicht ruanda und
dass er nicht weiß was mit seiner firma
geschah ist natürlich schlimm aber ihre
firma ist gestorben wie hier unzählige
menschen gestorben sind
die angehörigen wissen zum teil auch
nicht auf welche art und wann sie
ermordet wurden
so schlimm und trank ist es sollte uns
nicht daran hindern gute sachen zu
machen die uns weiterbringen
als wir hierher kamen habe ich von ihrer
firma gehört die dachplatten aus papyrus
herstellte
ich habe gefragt wo sind die betreiber
wie können wir die produktion wieder
aufnehmen
damals bekam ich keine information wer
dahinter steckt heute sind wir uns
damals nicht begegnet
wie gut er mit ruanda in den besitz von
christel ventures geraten ist dazu
konnte oder wollte auch der präsident
nicht sagen
aber immerhin hat er versprochen dem
nachzugehen
es war für christoph decken eine gewisse
genugtuung dass der präsident sein
produkt tatsächlich kannte und für den
wiederaufbau gebraucht hätte nach fünf
tagen wird seine reise in die
vergangenheit mit einem letzten ausflug
aufs land zu ende
es ist gut sie dass ich nur mal ja aber
kopien nach 20 jahren und mehr das
normale getan
es ist doch immer ein großer
unsicherheitsfaktor bei mir sie einen
fehler an fehler gemacht was ist
eigentlich passiert
es ist denkbar dass der präsident
nachdem es gestern doch dort empfangen
hat sehr nett und interessiert am
schluss zeit hat ja sicher firma die
hätte ich gern hier bald vielleicht
kommt dann dem präsident jähriger der
besucher fuhr dann werden wir wieder
morgen wenn sowie die
[Musik]